Guess who's back?
Well, you probably don’t need to be told,
since it's almost guaranteed that you and
everyone you know has been freaking out about
his return since the moment the Avengers:
Endgame trailer dropped.
Yeah, you guessed it: it’s Hawkeye.
“What, you didn’t see that coming?”
One person who has only just recently addressed
Clint Barton’s return to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is the man behind the bow himself,
Jeremy Renner.
Sure, the actor has been teasing fans for
months on end about his connection to the
fourth Avengers film, posting plenty of cheeky
snaps on Instagram with Avengers-related captions,
but Renner has mostly kept quiet about how
exactly Hawkeye will fit into the upcoming
movie’s story.
That all changed when Marvel Studios rolled
out the trailer for Endgame, which revealed
Renner back in action not as Hawkeye, but
as Hawkeye's alter-ego Ronin.
After the trailer debuted, Renner took to
Twitter to share the footage that Marvel had
released that morning, posting to his 4 million
followers:
"Good to see you all again!
Coming in hot!"
Renner then headed to his Instagram account
and uploaded the teaser poster for the film,
which confirmed the movie’s earlier-than-expected
release date of April 26th, 2019.
Renner’s caption read:
"Anyone seen the trailer??"
Obviously, that’s kind of a silly question,
considering Endgame’s trailer set a new
record by racking up 289 million views in
the first 24 hours after its release.
When Marvel fans first learned that Hawkeye
and Ant-Man wouldn't appear in Avengers: Infinity
War, the rumor mill began to crank out fan
theory after fan theory regarding their unknown
whereabouts.
Infinity War did offer a brief explanation,
but it was pretty blink-and-you’ll-miss-it.
“Where’s Clint?"
"After the whole Accord situation he and Scott
took a deal, it was too tough on their families
they're on house arrest.”
After Thanos loaded up the Infinity Gauntlet
with all six Infinity Stones, snapped his
fingers and wiped out half the universe in
the final moments of Infinity War, fans started
to freak, and who can blame them?
Audiences watched as beloved heroes like Scarlet
Witch, Star-Lord, Spider-Man, Black Panther
and many more faded into dusty nothingness.
Worse still, Hawkeye and Ant-Man's fates were
left unclear since they weren't present on
the battlefield, and so audiences were left
to wonder whether those two heroes had become
victims of the Decimation.
Since Infinity War's ending, we've thankfully
learned that both Clint Barton and Scott Lang
are still alive.
The end-credits scene of Ant-Man and the Wasp
confirmed Scott Lang’s survival, albeit
in a perilous state, stuck in the Quantum
Realm with no obvious means of escape.
After a long wait, the Endgame trailer confirmed
that Hawkeye also survived the Decimation.
But while Ant-Man seems in relative good spirits
in Endgame, Hawkeye is a different story.
Suited up as Ronin, he looks as sleek as he
does intimidating, and it's evident that he's
gone through exactly the kind of trauma that
would push someone to transform into a rogue
assassin.
Steve Rogers stating that the heroes lost
friends, family and a part of themselves following
Infinity War implies Hawkeye's family may
have disintegrated in the snap, spurring him
into becoming Ronin.
This is just a rumor for now, but Infinity
War and Endgame directors Joe and Anthony
Russo had previously promised to cook up something
special for Hawkeye.
“I knew I should have stretched.”
Throughout shooting on Endgame, Renner had
been generous with behind-the-scenes teases,
often uploading selfies taken on-set.
In June, the actor teased on Instagram:
"Got this feelin I need to SUIT up soon."
Renner also turned things up a notch when
he uploaded a photo of himself from the last
day of filming on Endgame.
And while his re-emergence in the franchise
was all but inevitable, it's nice to know
that Renner can now talk a little more openly
about Avengers: Endgame.